hey guys welcome back to the channels
channel in the news cosmic wonder cosmic
culture we just got the brand new first
look for spider-man into the
spider-verse and we're all just going to
check it out here together so here we go
home
[Music]
[Music]
little times
[Music]
miles
when how did she
how did you get how have you been
it's a long story the effects look even
is this the rupee actually the animation
is better they amped it up a time my
dorm room
of course he's trying to clean his room
hey are these
i missed you too
so
what are you doing here
i mean i
thought
that's so
the animation is cooler somehow
i mean
she throws her hood on
he's in love
that's awesome
across the spider groups
that's right
oh man that looks i covered 20 22. dang
it here wow they did such a good job
amping up the animation for that
i'm not gonna lie when the first one
came out before i wasn't like that
excited to see it and then i saw it i
was like wow this is fantastic but this
is like i'm like really excited to see
this this is like the animation yeah
this is like she's wearing a spiderman
shirt we're out and about right now
he's wearing a spider-man shirt i mean
yeah
spider-man hype is at an all-new high
and honestly
let's just keep it going it is coming
out after it right we have to wait like
you know 10 months or whatever but
there's still going to be a pretty big
hype on it so yeah let us know what you
all thought about that whether you're on
marvel minute news with ali cosmo wonder
me cosmic culture from chris let us know
what you thought in the comments down
below and i'm super excited for this so
subscribe
notification bell thank you guys so much
we appreciate it and we'll see you on
our next one and i'll say woof woof
because that's what i do
cosmic culture bye